President Trump says he wants to use the
military to secure the border with
Mexico until the u.s. can build a wall
there the president said he is studying
border security options with defense
secretary James Madison one option is to
send National Guard troops to help
Border Patrol chip Reid is at the White
House with the latest chip good morning
well good morning the president is
stepping up the tough talk on illegal
immigration after making little progress
on his signature campaign promise to
build a border wall the White House says
the president has directed a vigorous
administrative strategy to confront the
threat until we can have a wall in
proper security we're going to be
guarding our border with the military at
a meeting with Baltic leaders Tuesday
President Trump called for sending
troops to the southern border to stop
illegal immigration but provided little
detail I think that it's something we
have to do mr. Trump seized on reports
of a caravan of over a thousand migrants
who have been dispersing in Oaxaca
Mexico according to the Mexican
government the caravan has taken place
every year at this time since 2010
thought they were going to just walk
right through Mexico and right through
the border while presidents have in the
past sent the National Guard to the
border to assist Customs and Border
Patrol they did not act as law
enforcement personnel in 2010 President
Obama sent 1200 National Guard members
to help battled drug smuggling and
illegal immigration and in 2006
President Bush sent six thousand Guard
members to assist the Border Patrol in
both deployments soldiers had no
authority to detain immigrants because
federal law prohibits using active-duty
troops to conduct law enforcement
activities in the United States unless
authorized by Congress president Trump's
call to militarized the border comes as
illegal border crossings last year were
at the lowest levels since 1971 there's
nothing that I see right now happening
on the us-mexico border that would
constitute an insurrection Admiral James
Winnefeld was vice chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff under President Obama
and warns against using the US military
if the president tried to use military
forces in an inappropriate way he would
be violating federal law the National
Guard says it has not received any
notice about sending troops to the
border
and in a statement the Mexican
government says it's immigration policy
is quote a sovereign issue implemented
according to law john chip read for us
at the White House thank you chip